i'm about to start my first year
teaching in a public school i never
thought i would have to you know weigh
my options on going to a private or
public based on being you know in this
situation with crt and teachers being
forced not to teach what advice might
you have for me and second where do you
see this fight going and how could the
public schools return back to normalcy
the good news is that a lot of the local
school boards are really pushing back
and providing information to the local
school boards and to the citizenry at
large as to what's happening inside the
the classroom is really really important
we get leaks at daily wear every day and
we're able to really push those pretty
hard a reporter from uh from our our
website actually uh who was reporting
first on sort of the the uprising in
loudon county that has turned into such
a major issue i'm teaching and learning
yeah exactly so so loud and county
there's real pushback and that that is
absolutely wonderful and i think that as
long as parents stay active and teachers
are a big part of that because again
most parents have no transparency as to
what's happening in the classroom
teachers who convey that whether it is
through leaks or whether it is or
whether it is publicly are doing the
world a favor